hello and welcome to a lordsofgaming.net
special preview of iron harvest iron
harvest is the upcoming
uh rts game from king art games
set in the alternate universe of 1920
plus
it has been described as a diesel punk
uh themed
alternative universe set just after
uh world war one so
we got the pleasure of playing against
some of the developers
in which you probably have watched
already on this channel um in a 3v3
environment but i want to take some time
and talk about what really makes iron
harvest special
in this preview just ahead as the review
for this game is just around the corner
so we're going to be talking a little
bit about what is available
in the current state of the game because
the game is currently available
in open beta on steam so you can if you
find this game interesting it's
something that you want to play
you can go right to steam right now and
you can play the open beta it has
multiplayer
and it has the first uh five campaigns
uh
stories i believe and what you can
experience in this game
is truly incredible um as someone who
has a deep
and uh very knowledgeable rts background
as one of my favorite
genres i really am taking take it away
with this game because
it really central it really is such a
beautiful
example of what makes rts games so much
fun
it's such a balance of what is your
strategy
and how can you execute that strategy um
right now
in this gameplay footage you're seeing
you're seeing one of the first uh
campaign of missions um which kind of
gives you a basis of what to expect in
the game
not necessarily in terms of its scale
the scale of this game is
incredible but i didn't want to show off
too much because if you find this
interesting
you'll want to experience some of the
stuff yourself so in this first campaign
mission it's going to show you some
basic cover
techniques and how to move your troops
around this
game is truly incredible in how well
uh the first uh few story missions that
are available
really teach you the mechanics of this
game and how you can really improve on
it right off the bat and
it's one of the key focuses of iron
harvest is
that i've had just as much fun playing
the single player aspect of the game as
i have
with skirmishing with my friends as well
which is a really unique aspect with rts
games because some rts games feel more
geared to the campaign while others feel
more geared towards the multiplayer
iron harvest is kind of like a perfect
blend of both
of those um playstyles
so you can have a blast with your
friends with this game as well as
you know play the campaign and really
enjoy the campaign i would recommend
uh when you're starting the game though
to definitely check out the campaign
first because there is a lot
to this game and how the cover mechanics
work so i want to talk a little bit
about the cover mechanics
so what really separates this game from
say your
age of empires or age of mythology or
any of those great classic rts games
those are my personal favorites
is of course the cover system and how uh
terrain plays a very important factor
in how you navigate and negotiate
your uh battles against other players or
the ai
so basically when you're using a cover
system you can order your troops to go
behind cover
and provides them a more defensive
position now
this can also lead to disadvantages as
well depending on what angle you're on
it leaves it requires you to be adaptive
and always be focusing on
what units you have different troops and
enemy types all come into play as well
in classic rts fashion
you know certain troops work against ba
against other troops better
uh for example you can't see it in in
this clip in particular but
standard infantry gets absolutely cut
down by
flamethrower troops but are also weak to
other varieties
of troops as well so it kind of gives
you that classic rts balance of
okay so my enemies playing these uh
characters so i need to play these
characters to counter them
but also the terrain and the environment
around you plays a huge factor into that
and one of the
coolest aspects of iron harvest i really
want to touch on
is the minimalist approach to building
and when i say a minimalist approach to
building i don't mean
necessarily that you can't build a lot
it's about
the options you have when you build so
basically when it comes to
making your troops and building up your
forces
you have two main uh production
facilities you can use your main
headquarters to produce your basic
engineers and your basic
foot infantry but you will need
basically a workshop that produces your
mechs
and a barracks that will produce your
troops everything else
is defensive based or defensive
orientated
or your base defense or cutting off key
choke
points or anything along those lines
from pill boxes to
mg nests to just simple sandbags to make
cover
uh for your troops and that's kind of
what makes this game really
special is the ability to craft the map
around what your game plan is there's a
perfect example of this
is when fighting cover to cover
sometimes if you have engineers in your
ranks you can build sandbag
fortifications if you want to hold the
point
because during multiplayer games of iron
harvest
you have to capture and hold points to
earn victory points
so the person with the most control
points obviously wins the game
or if you eliminate your opponent
however
what's really unique with iron harvest
is that you can build
defensive fortifications around these
control points so
say for example you take a bridge a
control point that's located near a
bridge you can build sandbags
uh up and mg nests around that
to better defend your control points you
can hold it longer
this is different than most rts games
where you would have to
simply use your soldiers to try to uh
to hold and choke the enemy off in
different areas
you have to use everything you have to
use the terrain you can use the
buildings you can hide and stash
uh troops and units inside uh
village houses and uh outlying buildings
um and this provides a certain element
of surprise that you can have on your
enemy as well as providing defensive
capabilities
it's just a really unique feature um and
what i really love is that
in the three different classes of iron
harvest you have your roost viets you
have your polanya
and you have your saxony all of these
different factions really provide you a
different uh play style polania is more
based around being middle it's very good
on defense it's very good on offense
but uh the roost fiats i've found in my
experience so far have been
astounding at offense meanwhile
saxony is very well geared to defense so
if you can take a point it's
really easy to hold it with saxony so
these factions really play
well around your play style and that's
what i think i most enjoy about this
game is it
took me very little time to find a
faction that really
spoke to me and really made me enjoy the
game this game's very
v has a very steep learning curve but
once you get a couple of games and it
starts feeling very natural and it's
very quick
and the games are intense and you you
you can lose hours in this game
very very quickly um because of how
immersive this game is
it's a wonderful game the soundtrack is
absolutely fantastic i can
not say enough about how great the
soundtrack is
uh from what i've heard so far in the
game um
and i'm just overall really impressed um
with the game as a cohesive whole from
what i've played in this open demo
because in the open demo in a very rare
form a very transparent
move and i want to give the developers
king art games a lot of credit for this
is that they did a rather brilliant move
this game has been basically an open
beta for the past few weeks
and in this open beta you are allowed to
access five campaign missions and
various skirmish maps and play
uh multiplayer games so you can pretty
get it you can get a pretty good idea of
what you want out of this game
and kind of one of the most brilliant
things about iron harvest
from what i've played so far has been
the fact that
it is really good at both of these
things
it is very balanced it is a lot of fun
it's great to play with my friends
especially if they're not good at rts
games because if you have a couple games
under your belt you can
really really take it to your friends
and it's just
overall a brilliant game and the
campaign is
very addictive um i finished the first
five campaign missions and left going
i want more and that's something very
rare that i find from an rts game
um because most of the time with rts
games the campaign feels
incredibly tacked on this is not the
case with iron harvest there is a very
interesting story that they've managed
to
lay out in front of you um with the
first five campaign missions i'm very
interested to see where the story leads
and there was mentions of a fourth
faction within the story
so i'm kind of interested to see what
that means uh going forward
post launch of course so it'll be very
interested to see
what more they do with this game it's
just overall it's a
brilliant game um and i really think
it's going to be a sleeper hit of
of the fall it releases september 1st
on pc steam there will be a console port
coming in 2021
it is currently as i've stated
previously it is available in open beta
on
steam you can search it on the steam
store at iron harvest
so i hope you have enjoyed this brief
preview
of iron harvest and i hope you've taken
away something from this or that you
will go check out this
uh very interesting and uh
mechanical game from king art
games um and we will have a full review
as well as guides on lords of gaming.net
in the coming week as the game goes past
review embargo
and releases on tuesday so we hope
to that you guys will tune into that
coverage as well
and we hope you guys have a blast with
what you have seen from
iron harvest so far and there is much
more to come
for in terms of content from us so i
appreciate you checking this out
once again i am nicholas downey the
assistant editor and
chief of lordsandgaming.net you can find
me
on twitter at undead 3xbi of course
don't forget to follow lordsofgaming.net
on twitter as well we will see you guys
next time